[Música]
una estampida en yemen deja por ahora 78
muertos según los reportes oficiales aún
no se conoce Qué hizo que la gente
entrara en pánico en la capital sana lo
que se sabe es que estaban en un centro
educativo recibiendo donaciones por el
final del ramadán
fracasó el segundo intento de Establecer
un cese al fuego en Sudán el ejército y
los paramilitares de las fuerzas de
apoyo rápido pactaron una tregua de 24
horas a partir de la noche de este
miércoles pero los combates continuaron
en las calles de jartum la capital
mientras que miles de personas intentan
huir y los alimentos comienzan a
escasear
y el presidente de Cuba Miguel Díaz
canel seguirá cinco años más en el poder
asamblea nacional lo designó nuevamente
por una votación casi unánime el gran
reto que seguirá enfrentando es la
economía que ha sido duramente golpeada
en el último tiempo
buenas noches y bienvenidos a las
noticias de France 24 los saluda María
Clara calle
iniciamos en África hubo una estampida
en la capital de yemen sanam que es
controlada por los Rebeldes utties los
fallecidos serían 78 según afirmó una
cadena nacional el director del
departamento de salud de la ciudad mutar
almurini la estampida Fue en un colegio
en el área de babal yemen mientras
repartían donaciones por el ramadán el
Ministerio del interior dijo en un
comunicado que dos de los comerciantes
que organizaron el evento fueron
arrestados y que están investigando los
hechos
[Aplausos]
en Sudán ya van cinco días de conflicto
y este miércoles fracasó un segundo
intento de cese al fuego entre el
ejército y los paramilitares de la
fuerza de apoyo rápido que son los
grupos que se enfrentan en teoría este
debía haber comenzado a las seis de la
tarde hora local pero testigos denuncian
que los enfrentamientos continuaron en
la capital jartum donde han huido miles
de personas los países vecinos como
Egipto y Arabia Saudita habían
presionado para esta tregua y poder
evacuar así a sus ciudadanos por otro
lado el ejército sudanés informó que
salió del país 177 militares de la
fuerza aérea egipcia los combates en
Sudán han dejado al menos 270 muertos y
2600 heridos según el Ministerio de
salud nacional
y otra de las consecuencias de estos
combates en Sudán es que miles de
personas siguen encerradas en sus casas
los heridos por ejemplo no han podido
asistir a centros de salud mientras que
los ciudadanos no han podido comprar
alimentos y algunos elementos básicos ya
comienzan a escasear Por otra parte
varios organismos humanitarios
internacionales denuncian que no han
podido moverse a través de la capital
para llevar ayuda humanitaria veamos
Sudán al borde de una gran crisis
humanitaria Es solo el quinto día de
combates en jartum pero los residentes
de la capital ya experimentan el pánico
por la falta de servicios básicos a raíz
de los enfrentamientos entre el ejército
y las FARC el suministro de agua y luz
han sido cortados en ciertas partes de
la ciudad además muchos comercios han
cerrado sus puertas por el miedo a ser
objeto de la violencia lo que ha
provocado un desabasto en medicamentos e
insumos básicos
Voy a instalar
Desafortunadamente la capital hartum
está colapsada desde el sábado pasado
Aquí no hay agua en las tuberías ni en
los depósitos el agua almacenada está
casi agotada
a pesar de la urgencia por ayuda las
organizaciones humanitarias se
encuentran imposibilitadas para actuar
Naciones Unidas ha denunciado agresiones
y violencia sexual en contra de
trabajadores humanitarios Durante los
combates en jartum además la movilidad
de asistencia es sumamente compleja
consecuencia del constante intercambio
bélico entre ambos bandos
la verdad es que en estos momentos es
casi imposible prestar ninguna
asistencia humanitaria en jartum y sus
alrededores recibimos llamadas de
diversas organizaciones y personas
atrapadas pidiendo que las evacuen desde
hace cuatro días la gente no tiene agua
ni comida y la electricidad ha sido
totalmente desconectado en algunos
lugares
Excel en 2022 Sudán se posicionó en el
lugar 172 en el índice de desarrollo
humano uno de los más bajos del mundo el
conflicto actual podría acentuar esta
condición y generar una nueva crisis
humanitaria en una nación africana
teórica pasamos a América la asamblea
nacional de Cuba ratificó al presidente
Miguel Díaz canel para un segundo
periodo presidencial de cinco años
durante su primer gobierno la economía
cubana cayó un 11% en 2020 a causa de la
pandemia y ahora el reelecto presidente
deberá seguir enfrentando la difícil
situación económica empeorada por la
inflación y las sanciones de Estados
Unidos por ahora continuará con las
políticas que ha defendido hasta el
momento Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
no hubo sorpresas pero casi unanimidad
con más del 97% de los votos Miguel Díaz
canel accedió a un segundo mandato en
Cuba
declaro Miguel Díaz Bermúdez presidente
de la república de Cuba serán otros
cinco años con el timonel de los
destinos de la isla y un último periodo
según la constitución en lo que pueda
representar el último acto de formación
de gobierno en presencia de los
fundadores políticos del país Díaz canel
tuvo palabras para los que lo adversan
Pero no puedo dejar de contrastar
actitudes la de los que critican del
modo más efectivo luchando haciendo
mostrando o creando soluciones y la de
aquellos que solo ven los errores y las
culpas de otros a su vez el jefe de
estado propuso a Manuel marrero para
desempeñarse como Primer Ministro
mandato ratificado por la asamblea la
máxima dirección del país se mantiene
intacta solo el consejo de ministros
sufrió leves cambios seis nuevos
integrantes fueron propuestos de la
generación de guerrilleros de Fidel solo
uno se mantiene Ramiro Valdez Menéndez
próximo a cumplir 91 años quien se
desempeña como viceprimer ministro
varios son los retos que enfrenta el
mandatario para sus próximos cinco años
entre ellos tomar un rumbo propio y las
renovaciones que ello implica con la
inercia de este primer mandato en que lo
que primo es somos continuidad y la
rigidez ideológica frente al pragmatismo
económico o si introducirá los cambios
que todo el mundo Espera que se produzca
Cuba viene golpeada por las
consecuencias de la pandemia un
endurecimiento de las sanciones de
Estados Unidos en las que Joe no ha dado
marcha atrás y dificultades internas
como escasez de combustible y un aumento
en el costo de vida que ha generado
protestas inéditas retos para los que el
quinto presidente de Cuba desde 1959
tendrá una segunda oportunidad para
encontrar soluciones
la ley de derecho de los padres en la
educación a la que los críticos llaman
como no digas gay aplicará ahora para
todos los grados escolares en Florida
Estados Unidos así el departamento de
Educación extendió la Norma que
inicialmente aplicó solo para primaria y
en las aulas no se podrá hablar de
identidad de género ni de orientación
sexual lluís Muñoz nos cuenta
es una de las muchas guerras culturales
de Estados Unidos la de la orientación
sexual y cómo abordarla en el sistema
educativo Florida expandió su ley
conocida como no digas gay los maestros
ahora no podrán enseñar sobre el tema y
sobre identidad de género en ningún
grado escolar las únicas excepciones
serán cuando le exijan los estándares
estatales o como parte de la instrucción
de salud reproductiva además la cámara
prohibió la atención de brindar atención
médica para transiciones de género en
menores el uso del baño que no sea el
del sexo asignado al nacer y la
presencia de niños en espectáculos de
Drag Queen el gobernador ronde santis
dice luchar contra el progresismo y las
diversidades conocidas como Wow
esta agenda izquierdista la ideología
Walk es una amenaza Para nuestras
libertades nuestros resultados finales
no nos rendimos a la mafia woke Florida
es donde lo Walk va a morir
a medida que de santis legisla también
llegan protestas en este caso de los
estudiantes de educación superior que
serían los próximos afectados por las
reformas ultraconservadoras los
republicanos quieren eliminar la teoría
crítica de la raza y la teoría queer de
las universidades
estamos muy preocupados con toda la
censura y todo el borrado que están
tratando de hacer con El currículo
creemos que las clases son un espacio
para el pensamiento libre crítico donde
tener conversaciones difíciles
recientemente de santis ha promulgado
una ley que prohíbe el aborto después de
las seis semanas y está en una guerra
abierta con Disney la compañía se opuso
la ley no digas gay y ron de santis
quiere ahora limitar la supervisión de
Disney de sus parques temáticos medidas
con las que busca avalarse entre los
conservadores de Cara a las elecciones
primarias del partido republicano
[Aplausos]
la Corte Suprema de Justicia de Estados
Unidos no se pronunció este miércoles
sobre la píldora abortiva mifepristona
como se esperaba y en cambio extendió
dos días más la pausa que ordenó para
decidir de fondo sobre el tema El juez
Samuel alito precisó que la sentencia
final se conocerá el viernes la corte de
debate la orden del juez Federal de
Texas
que impuso limitar la disponibilidad de
la pastilla alegando que la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos la fda No tenía sustentos
clínicos suficientes para verla aprobado
hace 20 años mientras la corte de toma
una decisión de fondo la mifepristona
sigue disponible
Canadá atraviesa una de las huelgas de
trabajadores más grandes de toda su
historia con un tercio de los servidores
públicos en paro ellos demandan un
aumento del salario ante la subida del
costo de vida y más flexibilidad en
teletrabajo cerca de 155.000
funcionarios entraron en huelga después
de que la alianza del servicio público
de Canadá no lograra un acuerdo con el
gobierno del Primer Ministro Justin
Rusia tendría botes espías disfrazados
de barcos pesqueros en el mar del Norte
los medios públicos de cuatro países
nórdicos publicaron una investigación
conjunta en la que afirman que Moscú
tiene equipos de vigilancia debajo del
agua para rastrear lugares que podrías
sabotear pero Moscú niega los
señalamientos Aquí les contamos
a simple vista parecen ser botes
pesqueros comunes pero en realidad
podrían ser barcos espías rusos según
una reciente investigación que sugiere
que con ellos se transportan equipos de
vigilancia submarina y se trazan mapas
de sitios clave para un posible Sabotaje
para el servicio de inteligencia danés
estas no son noticias nuevas
el servicio de seguridad e inteligencia
es consciente de que históricamente y en
la actualidad Rusia realiza el espionaje
en Dinamarca realizan actividades de
inteligencia
Rusia hace esto principalmente para
expandir su espacio de maniobra de
política exterior y de seguridad desde
Moscú y
según el documental la operación rusa
comenzó en el archipiélago noruego de
svalbard en enero del año pasado
la región alberga una de las estaciones
de satélite más grandes del mundo los
datos meteorológicos las imágenes de los
aviones el tráfico marítimo todo se
transmite a través de estos cables
en términos de inteligencia poder tocar
un cable o recopilar información de un
cable que transmite grandes cantidades
de datos ayuda a obtener información muy
valiosa información la policía de
Noruega ha iniciado recientemente una
investigación sobre dos casos de
Sabotaje a cables marítimos pero
enfrenta dificultades para enjuiciar a
los pesqueros rusos que han aprovechado
las lagunas legales relacionadas con la
navegación en aguas Internacionales
El equipamiento de los pesqueros
modernos En comparación con los que se
usaban hace 20 años es bastante
impresionante por lo tanto navegan con
una excelente capacidad de mapeo del
lecho Marino que es Útil para fines
militares
Rusia ha negado las acusaciones diciendo
que son infundadas en noviembre pasado
un barco espía ruso fue avistado en
estas áreas donde hay parques eólicos
gasoductos submarinos y cables de
comunicación
el presidente de Francia Emanuel macún
realizó su primer encuentro con el
público desde que promulgó su polémica
reforma a las pensiones en la región de
alsacia lo abuchearon y le expresaron su
rechazo a la Norma pero macron la
defendió Juan pupiales tiene los
detalles
un baño de masas
convertido en un balde de agua fría no
fueron saludos para el presidente de la
república fueron pedidos de dimisión y
hasta acusaciones de corrupción es el
sentir que se respira en las calles de
Francia luego de tres meses de protestas
contra la recién promulgada reforma
pensional que eleva la edad de
jubilación de 62 a 64 años
[Música]
sí grité y le dije que pelearemos que
vamos a luchar por poder jubilarnos a
los 60 años y que los franceses como
todos los franceses Seguiremos
expresando nuestro descontento no vamos
a pasar la página sobre esta reforma de
las pensiones
es el primer viaje a las regiones de
macron desde que promulgó el sábado la
reforma pensional texto que sacó
adelante evadiendo el voto de la
asamblea nacional el jefe de estado
eligió visitar la región de alsacia en
el gran este una zona que votó en
mayoría por él en la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales
y normal que ustedes Es normal que se
exprese esta ira Ahí está también hay
personas que tienen otras motivaciones
que vinieron a saludarme otras que me
están apoyando estuvieron conmigo esta
mañana en una empresa que refleja la
diversidad de Francia no escuché ninguna
movilización esta vez para poder salir
adelante ir a las empresas y hacer cosas
sin embargo se nota ese enojo no
esperaba otra cosa pero no me va a
impedir seguir moviéndome por el país
porque hay que seguir actuando y salir
adelante
los principales sindicatos de Francia
han hecho un llamado para una nueva gran
movilización el primero de mayo día
internacional de los trabajadores
así llegamos al final de las noticias
los invitamos a que sigan con nosotros
aquí en France 24
[Música]